Hey, what's going on is bill burns,
is Sanford the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on.
You just see now you weeks go in.
How your life is,
how you're feeling this day.
Um, uh, I'm not, I don't
know. I don't, you know,
you know I was supposed to get my
Invisalign off yesterday. Right?
I was all excited.
This shit was supposed to take 16 weeks
and because I wore them like a fucking
lunatic, basically 24, seven occasion,
I'd smoke a cigar or I do is set.
If I did a long set and I didn't feel
like spitting all over the stage,
I would take him out.
But a lot of times it just left them in
one time I left them in when I smoked a
cigar. That was a bad move. Bad move.
I just sit there and brush and pluck an
hour so there wouldn't be fucking all
brown.
Hey.
So last time I saw my
dentist, he's like, oh gee.
Willikers it wouldn't
wearing them so much.
I think we'll be done by the 13th week.
And I was like, you gotta be kidding me.
This is a great,
I tried not to get excited.
I tried to be like, okay, well
I'm supposed to be, you know,
just mentally just keep being prepared
for the end of March when these things
are going to be off. So anyway,
so I go to the dentist, right?
And I'm wearing them and I'm wearing
them and I'm driving over, I'm wearing,
I'm chewing on the stupid sponge to make
sure the fucking trays all the way down
and all of that shit.
So I show up and he,
you know, takes it, takes
off. He's all, he's a good,
oh man. Wow. You really would.
You'd see when you comply, blah,
blah, blah blah. But these good,
and I'm sitting there going,
don't get excited.
Don't cause he cause kid comes to
however only I think we gave enough two
fucking weeks. I was waiting for that
shit. Right? But he doesn't, he goes,
see these still good enough to
take them off today. I was like,
you've gotta be kidding me.
I did it. Fucking did it.
This is like going into the fucking
Stanley Cup playoffs. All right.
And just sweeping everybody. See
you play like fucking, I dunno.
Let's see if you went
seven games times four,
that's 12 above about 28 fucking
games or you could just play 16.
I felt like I just played 16 games.
Fresh is a fucking daisy.
I'm ready to go another round. You already
handed me the trophy, right? So I said,
all right. So he seats taking the
fucking clips off or whatever.
He's filing them down and shit.
And he's like, uh, I go, okay,
so an ally you have to do now is just
where this tray at night when I sleep for
the rest of my life so they don't go back,
which is not picked deal.
I'm asleep at the fuck. Do
I care? All right. He goes,
no, no. Uh, this final tray.
You have to wear this for
the next three months.
And then we give to the overnight
tray and it's just like,
and your initial pitch,
I still would have fucking it,
but why are you full?
Just tear the bandaid off.
Okay.
I could've just mentally got myself like
go right the next six months of my life
is going to suck.
You got me all excited about 16 weeks
and then 13 and then it's going to happen
and then, oh by the way, by the way,
here's another three months onto
your sentence. She not out yet. Oh,
fucking bug me. You know,
cause you know what it was.
Cause when he went initially
went to sell it to me,
he was too afraid that if he told me I
was going to be six months that I wasn't
going to do it. That's basically what it
is that you know, I get it. Capitalism,
it's sales.
I really wanted to,
I didn't say anything. I, you know,
what are you going to eat in a day?
I got fucking straight teeth and made
it works. The shit definitely works.
I am thrilled. I am elated with
it. I just, you know what I mean?
That's like something your wife does.
Okay.
Built the team. Is there
anything in the world, Bill,
that you can't turn around and blame
women for? All right, you're right.
I'm being emotional.
Being a cunt.
Okay.
Fucking three more months. I
turned 53 months. You know,
you think I'm gonna have a fucking braces.
I don't know about you,
but that's not what I might,
that's not one of my life's goals.
MMM.
So anyways, so now what's going on is
he took the fucking hooks off my tab.
I'm just giving you guys the blow by
blow. This guy's a great dentist. Okay.
You know,
could have been a little
more straightforward about
how long this was going to
fucking take. You know,
just dump the ball over.
My head stopped like taking little
spoonfuls and putting him out of his head.
Okay.
Can you handle that?
Yeah.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
I ain't know what the fuck does he know?
Just so now the hooks are
off these fucking things
and uh, this is like getting out of jail
cause you just don't get out of jail.
They go from maximum to
like medium to minimum two.
You're living in some guy's fucking
house and you can go out and go get a
fucking Bagel and you've got to come
back and report to somebody. This is,
this is how the Invisalign's going down.
Um,
I am in the,
uh,
the halfway house or the fucking minimum
security building up this shit now,
the three months, whatever.
I don't even fucking notice
him. I'm, I'm Kinda over it.
I did have two event I did at the vent
on it, on the podcast about it, but it's,
it's just the fucking yellow.
Just,
just tell me what I'm in
for so I can prepare for it.
It's like one of those fucking movies
where you sit in your God Damn cubicle at
your desk and you finish your
stack of papers. You're like, ah,
and you fucking put
your foot up on a desk.
Guy Comes back with
another stack of papers,
you know.
Anyways, anyways, um, oh, fucking,
uh,
Billy Boston Bruin
bandwagon is jumping on.
I've watched the last three games,
to be honest. You, I, I missed,
I turned on the last Bruins game or you
know, I got a kid now, so I do what I can.
All right. I put the game on when
it was four to one. All right.
I watched a beat the
Black Hawks on Saturday.
I watched them lose on Sunday and
on, I put the game on, it was,
they were down four to one. I was like,
Jesus Christ, every time I fuck a week,
they do nothing. But when,
whenever I turned them on,
they fucking loose. And um,
so I got the game on.
You don't medium volume.
I'm in the kitchen with my beautiful
daughter and I'm making her some dinner.
I came in, what the hell? I made her.
She likes these meatballs, right?
With the vegetables
and that type of stuff.
And now what are we trying to
keep her away from? Uh, you know,
all the sugar in that type of shit.
However, you know, occasionally, you know,
my kid's not going to not have McDonald's.
You know what I mean?
I'm not going to take it to that
level where the kid is like, oh,
can I have some dessert and be like, yeah,
here's a Kiwi or some shit like that.
Even though you probably should do that.
I don't know.
MMM.
So anyways, I, I have the game I'm in,
I'm out in the kitchen and then I
just hear Jack Edwards going crazy.
Three goals.
It's 77 seconds.
It's like come running in. Like what
the, what the fuck just happened?
Long Story Short,
the Bruins scored,
they scored five goals in the
third period to win six to five.
The last one was an empty net.
MMM.
They scored him so fast.
I don't even know who fucking scored him.
I can't even remember who the hell
scored them pasta knock out one of them.
Uh, but I do know that we also, uh,
lost like three guys got
hurt during the game.
Tory crew Debraski in fucking
Zidane Know Ciara. But I,
I looked at the replay
because I missed those place.
They didn't look a sitting on my couch
and not having to do a Dur. The paint,
they didn't look too bad.
Um,
charter went down like someone at a public
skating rink is what that looked like.
And then he just slid into the board.
Looks like he hit his shoulder.
He was walking off fine.
You don't,
when he was off the ice and he was going
through the tunnel, he seemed all right.
Granted he's also like nine feet tall
and can do like over 40 pull ups,
which makes no fucking
sense at 40 41 years of age.
It's easy for the little guys because
they don't have to travel as far.
But to bring that giant body and all
the way the fuck down, it's like,
it's like the little guys going
up like two, two steps and he's,
he's got to run up like nine flights
of stairs every time he does. It's,
it's unreal. So he's tough as
nails. I think we'll be back.
I don't know what happened to Tory Craig
and uh, the Brusk hopefully if I just,
I dunno,
got a mild sort of a bounce his brain
around a little bit, but uh, anyways,
what playing the Florida panthers tonight?
Seven 30 my four 30 my time,
seven 30 east coast time and
the panthers fight the most,
have the most fighting
majors in the NHL this year.
And it's like some pathetically low
number. I think they were in the,
they've had like 20 fighting majors.
They average of fight, like basically,
you know, every three
games. Um, it's just,
it's just completely out of the fucking
league and it sucks. But granted,
I'm not the guy who I don't have to fight,
right.
I don't have to walk around dealing with
the concussions and all of that shit.
But, you know, just as a fan, I
miss it. So they got them on, uh,
they got them today, Thursday, and
then Saturday when I'm up in, uh,
Ontario, they got the lightening, so
they got some big games coming up Monday.
The blue jackets,
I don't even know how they're do because
I haven't been watching anything,
but I'm back.
I'm back on fucking bored here.
A lot of new faces and shit. But, um,
you know, like I said, I've watched
so many games in the last 10 years,
the 820 regular season games,
I bet I saw at least, you know,
500 of them.
So I missed like the last fucking
60 that they had this year.
Essentially. I only saw maybe five
games this year. Uh, it's embarrassing,
but, uh, which sucks because I watched
them totally dismantled a team,
you know, four years ago or something and
go all the way back down to rebuilding.
And I was like,
I'm going to watch this whole rebuild.
And this year when it all fucking
came together, um, I mean,
what am I complaining about? Oh,
I had to go and become a dad,
which is the most amazing
fucking thing ever. Um,
my little one's starting to try to
run now, which is hilarious. Um,
and also we've been doing
this thing where, uh,
when she's done with the toy and then
she wants to play with something else,
she has to put away the other
toy and she just has it down.
She likes it cause we applaud
every time she puts some way.
She's playing with these giant Lego's
today and we, and she wanted that.
She wanted to have this
bag of like, uh, you know,
multicolored fucking little like a, they
almost look like ping pong balls, right?
She wants to go play with those fucking
things. So it's just like, all right,
well you got to put away
the Lego blocks first.
So she starts putting away
and I'm applauding on everyone
that she does and then
there's two stuck
together and she fucking,
she pulled them apart before she put
him away. And as a parent right there,
you're like, oh my God, my kid
is a genius. You know, like,
like you have Einstein as a
kid rather than, it was a, uh,
a pretty logical step that
they would just able to make,
but it's still thrilling. Everything
is fucking thrilling. So anyways,
um, this morning I go outside, right?
I play a little game on Thursday
when the trash comes out. Um, is,
I'm always listening for the garbage
truck. All right. Because, um,
now that I don't have a
dog, I mean, I still do.
It's still technically my dog and she's
in town this week and I've been taking
her on these long hikes every day.
It's been awesome. She looks great,
she just looks great and
she's so freaking happy.
And I told you for the
first time in her life,
she has another dog that she's friends
with, which she never did. You know,
she was never in that mindset when
someone with my limited skill set had her,
she tried to do you do, she usually
ignored bigger dogs and then little dogs.
Okay.
No little dogs would bark at her and she
would ignore them. And then bigger dogs,
she would also ignore them until
they started some shit, you know?
Okay.
I believe in the hip hop community that's
known as, uh, don't start. Nothing,
won't be nothing.
I believe that that's where my dog,
her mindset was from.
So anyways,
but I always fucking hated is
when the trash is out the barrels,
once they empty the fucking shit that the
trash truck comes by the garbage truck,
if you will empties the fucking thing out.
You have basically about a minute when
you live in loss of Congolese before some
fucking dog on and can't comes by and
takes a shit bag and throws in deer,
you're, uh, you're trashed route,
which I don't necessarily give a shit
this time of year because it's cold out.
But during the hot months,
you know,
to have some stamen bag of fucking Shit
marinating and your thing that's not
even from your own dog, it's so, it's
a little annoying. I appreciate it.
You keeping the city fucking clean.
But there is something about
that that it's just the,
it's a little fucking annoying.
So this morning I,
I've been hearing phantom garbage trucks
had been out there like nine times.
I only put away the recycling and,
uh,
I got a feeling while
I'm doing the podcast,
I'm going to hear this
fucking thing coming up the
street and I'm gonna tell you
right now, if I do, I'm,
I'm throwing down the mic.
I'm going to go out there and get in
and put that thing back inside. But, um,
I got a bunch of shit that I got handled.
I am back on Instagram.
Everybody.
I got to get the check next to my fucking
name so it's verified cause I guess
there's some people impersonating
me, which is really flattering. Um,
uh,
have not been on there since 2012.
Instagram was not something
that I gravitated towards,
but everybody keeps telling me, you
gotta get on it. You got to get on it.
And I was sick of fighting the youth there
and a, so I'm going to get back on it,
I guess. Um, it's been six
years since I'd done away. Okay.
It feels like I've had Invisalign on
for fucking 12 years at this point now.
It hasn't been that bad.
He says he had been that bad.
It's just that I got fucking
excited that it was over.
Okay,
honey, we done, I'm gonna blame
women again and we'd done this is it,
this is the last store and then it,
oh,
one claim to want to
look at some cosmetics.
Asshole.
Here's a question.
Why don't they have bars at malls?
You know,
I guess I do the kind of
like sports bars and shit.
Yeah.
I'm going to go into, hey,
what are you going to?
How do you take all the time you need?
I'm going to go in here and get
fucking loaded. Okay. I will.
I will do my best to help you with
the bags of shit that you don't need,
that you get. You're going to be carrying
out and then you're driving home.
How does that sound?
Okay.
Well,
I wanted to this ticket.
That's the thing. This is so good.
What's the exact thing that makes them a
great mother?
Makes them an annoying partner.
It's just like, just go do something
by yourself. Stop dragging me.
Why am I being such a jerk?
Because of my fucking Invisalign.
I like hanging out with my wife and I
had mentioned before when I didn't have
the hope that my Invisalign
was being taken off,
that I actually enjoy going to the mall
with my wife and kid there. I said it.
Uh,
all right.
Anyways,
I'm starting to understand tea by the way.
Yeah,
okay. I never understood it. It's like
it's hot as fuck. It Burns your tongue.
This isn't relaxing. It's like,
no stupid. It's hot as fuck.
So it activates what's ever in the
tea bag. And then once that's done,
you then take the fucking teabag out
and you throw it out like an Englishman.
All right? You don't keep it.
If you don't leave it in there,
like from sloppy American like me,
you take that out and you
let it fucking cooled down.
Now that everything's been accurate,
activate and then you drink it.
But the problem is is you've
just ordered a tea. That's fine.
But if he got something else coming,
by the time the fucking thing cools down,
you're, you're, you're,
you're a little Danish or whatever
the hell you ordered is already there.
Your crumpet, what the fuck is a
crumpet? Is that a biscuit and biscuits?
A cookie over there,
right?
Crump.
Oh,
it's what the C strumpet crop it.
Oh, it's an English muffin. Uh,
fuck out of you. That's all it is.
Teen crop it. I never, you know,
it's funny cause you know what I mean.
I,
I've been saying that I had no idea it
was always picked a little fucking round,
like Pale looking rich crack.
How to make crumpets BBC good food.
[inaudible] it would have been like a good
crop, but with their fucking, you know,
nobody a fucking crumpet with this
shit. Right. That's just something,
by the way,
has there ever not been an upbeat
chef and they always play like that?
Everything's going to be
okay. Music, you know,
flour, salt and sugar. Some Oregano,
some tomatoes.
Okay. Stirring it all the time.
He put it, I could do this shit.
I didn't know I could make
my own English muffins. Okay.
Is this like Philly cheese steak where
you don't say Philly cheese steak?
When you just say cheese steak,
when you're in England,
you don't say English muffin. You
don't even say muffin. You say crumpet
Oh God, this woman is either terrible or
unbelievable in bed. I don't know why.
I just thought that, oh, she's, she's
into the culinary arts. You know,
she figured, you know, she's in touch
with something. Who knows? You know,
sometimes people, they exact given one
talent. Sometimes it just, it's an,
it's an overall philosophy
that goes through. Um,
all right.
Let me read
a little bit of advertising here.
Uh,
then I'll talk about my pathetic attempts
to try to fucking learn this song for
the Goddamn comedy jam.
It has double bass in it and uh,
I haven't even really been
noticing, but like, um,
I'm left handed and I'm right handed at
the same time and that's fucking with my
double bass playing because sometimes
they have a tendency to lead with my left
foot. Other Times I have a tendency
to lead with my right foot.
You know, like if you're
going to do like a, uh,
like those separate the bat,
right,
whatever that is a fucking triplet right
before the snare hit where it's going
to be like right left, right or left,
right, left. I always go left right,
left.
I kind of feel like it's,
it's like if it's on the offbeat or
something like that, if it's on, you know,
if it's on one and two and three and
four and that should be right foot.
And if it's on the other ones,
I'm going left foot.
Right. I don't know. I have no idea.
But all I know was I'm trying to learn
this fucking song and the crashes on the
offbeat. And I do that with my right
foot. And then I think what I was doing,
I was,
when I was playing it up to speed and I
was just having fun and I didn't think
anybody was,
I was actually going to play it in front
of people and they were going to watch
me.
I think I was actually
playing left foot lead.
But then when I sat
down and broke it down,
I flipped it and I went from being able
to play it to up to tempo to drop in
like 30 bpm. And I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
And I have to have this song down
in like a week or so. So, um,
but I got the drum room now, so
I've just been, uh, you know,
something I learned from,
uh, Mike Johnston lessons,
which was a rather than practicing
at your limit to go down 10,
15,
even 20 bpms and just stay there for
like 10 minutes of really focused fucking
practice. Now I'm combining everything
shifted. Davey Lynch taught me.
I just kind of combined everything that
makes sense. And I've been able to start,
you know, going back up again
and uh, I get to tell you,
I don't know why the fuck I avoided
double bass drum and for so fucking long
it's, it's awesome. It's incredible.
And then all of this shit that I always
loved but wouldn't even attempt to play
along to prime is, uh, Pantera.
All those p bands that I love.
Um,
all of a sudden it's just like,
oh,
I kind of understand what's
happening right here. I mean,
I can't play it up to speed,
but it gives me somewhere to go.
And I remember I listened to a,
one of those lamb of God alums back in
the day and I was really fascinated with
a lot of the, the, the
drum beats that I was at,
Chris Adler came up and um,
I dunno,
it's like a, it's like anything, it's,
it's all of a sudden there's all this
new shit that you don't know you're
excited to sit down and
eat if it's like he kind of
okay,
learned what you know. And then you just
sort of sitting there, you actually get,
it's fucking weird.
You get like board, um,
and then you don't have any passion
and then you are already playing.
It's Shitty. And then you're going to
play it even fucking worse. So, uh,
very excited about that. Um, and to
finally have a fucking drum room,
I got to tell you,
I was up there fucking Waylon yesterday.
Not Saying I was playing well I was,
but I was hitting them is fucking hard.
Is that going to have us having a
great pouring sweat? Just, it's like,
it's fucking amazing. Can you played
double bass? All of a sudden it's like,
I don't think I need to do
the elliptical today. Uh,
that probably means my techniques sucks.
But that's the level of effort
that I was exerting. Yeah. So, um,
what's great though is darn if I
play during the day, my name was
okay
are at work and there's always somebody
with the leaf blower or a fucking
lawnmower playing. So I don't think
anybody's really going to hear me.
And I think it just, every day,
it's just middle of the day.
I play for like 90 fucking minutes. I can
have a great time, not piss anybody off.
And um, I don't know. And I, I think,
I think the dream has come true.
I'll tell you another fucking dream.
It would be if my Goddamn
fucking computer. Come on man.
Come back. Come back. What is the
problem? Where did you go? What happened?
I need to read advertising.
All right.
All you computer nerds
out there for some reason.
Hey there.
Oh,
now it came back when to like screensaver
mode and we wouldn't come back.
I don't know why it just,
it cause I just wrapped it
on the head like when fucking
Mel Howard would try to get fucking
Larry's attention here. Look,
can I get you can't just read
the, the uh, the advertising here.
I'm all over the place.
What did I do with it?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ belt.
Okay.
Do you see Trump just admitted that
he just completely made something up?
This guy like, sounds like me. You're
talking about how he said that, you know,
basically we had a trade deficit with
Canada, which I guess was not true.
This is when he was trying
to attack Nafta, saying,
this is the worst deal we ever signed.
And evidently, according to this site,
the Washington Post, I don't know
if this psychotically liberals,
so they're just snipping this,
I'm sure all you people on the right one,
it was the complete opposite.
It was Obama's fault. Um,
he said, despite having no idea
whether that was the case, he said,
the man who racked up more than
2000 false and misleading claims,
as president said, he insisted in
to Canadian prime as well. I mean,
I'm sure both sides would
debate that number. You know,
one side says 2000. The other
says three, uh, as president,
he insisted to Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau that the United States
runs a trade deficit with Canada's despite
quote having no idea whether that was
the case. Um, he said,
I said wrong, Justin, you do.
I didn't even know Trump said,
I had no idea. I just said,
you're wrong. You know why?
Because we're so stupid. That's where
that guy is out of his fucking mind.
And I know people like this.
They're just not present in United States.
He's admitting that he did something
wrong and then when he says why he did it,
he then includes how dumb
I am. It's just like, dude,
I didn't say this shit you did.
I'm not saying I'm not dumb.
That's like, you know, I've seen some,
I saw this guy get in trouble one
time and he was just going like, yeah,
you know when you fuck up,
you know,
okay,
you have to uh,
you have to come clean and own up to it.
It's like, it also, why are you talking to
me about it? I didn't do it. You did it.
I fucked up.
I need to come clean.
And he was speaking almost in like
a third person type of fuck it.
That's hilarious.
Okay.
That takes me back to
that fucking tee shirt.
Enough was enough talking about enough
already talking about paid women less
than guys. It's like fuck head. You're
a corporation. You are the one doing it,
not me. Now you going to act like
he never did it and profit off.
What the fuck he did wrong.
It's John Wayne Gacy having a
fucking shirt, uh, you know,
leave the kids alone
enough already. Right. Um,
and then he makes money off of it,
which she then uses to pay a lawyer and
he gets out of jail before they kill him.
Okay.
So anyways, uh, you know
why? Because we're so stupid.
Okay.
I would have respected him more
if he just said, you know why?
Because the American average
American is so fucking stupid date.
All you have to do is to say some shit.
And if you're wearing the right colored
tie, they're going to believe it.
They're not going to research. He
said that. Then I'd be like, yeah,
I totally agree with that.
And that also includes people
that are root for blue ties. Okay.
And that also includes
people in England and Canada.
Everybody know nobody's
fucking paying attention.
There's very few people that
pay attention to the level dead.
Like these talking heads on
TV who only argue one side.
And the fact that you're only arguing
one side, then at that point, I dunno.
How do you listen to them?
That's why I like Jimmy Dore.
Okay.
I like Jimmy Dore because
Jimmy Dore also leans left,
but he also trashes the shit out of
fucking Obama and calls him out on what a
fucking company, man he was.
That guy left the office,
he was worth over 80 million
bucks making 500 grand a year.
And everybody's looking at him like
he's fucking Gandhi. It's just like,
don't he see exact same
fucking not the exact same,
but essentially it's the same thing.
He's doing the same thing that the
guy before that had the red tie.
The guy before they had the blue
tie and every eight years were like,
it's the fucking blue ties.
We need a Red Dye. Um,
what you really need is you need
a revolution is what you need.
You need a revolution,
and you would have to literally kill
the super rich if you're ever going to
change. And who's Kidding Hill? You know
that. That's not gonna happen anymore.
I spend, that's why they're building
these robots. Everybody know these,
these robot. Oh God. Bill, you're
going off the deep end. Yes, I, yeah,
they're building these fucking robots.
That's what the fuck. It's four.
It's going to eliminate the
ability to ever a revolt.
Because here's the thing,
let's just say they turn this,
this country ever into a police state.
The people that make up our
armed services services,
the Bray a Webinar Omega by rob services,
they are all Americans.
And to have them turn their guns on their
own countrymen will be very difficult.
They would almost have to go
into a robot like mind state. Um,
let me see what I did there.
See what I did.
She had it all fucking hands high right
now when you talk to yourself into a
microphone and there's nobody to debate
or check fact check anything you're
saying,
you always stick the landing.
You always get always standing there,
you know,
fucking with the gold medal around your
neck as they play the national anthem.
Uh,
you all right?
I fucking a Gri were barely bar.
He made some great points.
That's because no one was
able to interrupt, hoard,
tell him he doesn't know what
he's talking about. Um, all right,
well the fuck is my, uh, I'm
figuring out all my passwords.
I'm really turning a new corner here.
I figured out,
finally figured out how to upload
something properly on a Dropbox without
yelling at it. I actually just sat
down and figured it out yesterday.
I flipped out and I fucking slammed my
computer down that because both my wife
and my daughter to jump. And I was just
like, what am I doing? What am I doing?
I walked downstairs and came back
up, you know, cooled off, came up.
I apologize to him
both. You know, this is,
this is what I'm doing right now where
I'm like the passing the baton of anger
in my family tree. Okay.
If I continue to tradition,
I just would have done that.
I would've blamed everybody in
the room and never apologize.
But now I walk away and um,
and I come back a few minutes later,
I apologize and I give her a hug,
a kiss in the room. That's
what I do. Okay. So, you know,
I'm not saying I'm not still fucked up.
I'm not saying people aren't
suffering being around me. I'm just,
I'm just saying that I
am trying. Uh, all right,
let me, uh, Sun basket everybody. Oh,
it's like having Ms Center
of the universe in a basket.
Sun Basket delivers delicious meat meal
kits right to your door making healthy
cooking easy and convenient
for any business.
Forget protein shaking and flavorless
diet food. Start cooking fresh.
I get to tell you something.
Those protein shakes.
If you look at like the
chemicals and all the crap,
all that shit that they gave
a Gnc, including the, uh,
the men's daily fucking pill that I take
total hypocrite that I bought it at GNC.
Uh, so much of that shit, it's
just like, how can that be
good for me? Yeah. Why? Oh,
there's so many chemicals. Forget protein
shaking and flavorless died. Food.
Start cooking fresh healthy meals with
delicious organic produce with Sun
Basket. Okay. 18 healthy options
to choose from every week,
including Paleo, gluten
free, lean and clean,
Vegan Mediterranean family options
and moral. However you want to do it,
they got the option for you.
Sun Basket makes it easy and convenient
to cook healthy, delicious meals at home.
No matter how much experience
you have in the kitchen,
now you get more options than ever.
Just go to sun basket app
to the sun basket APP and
pick from 18 weekly recipes.
Easily cook easily cooked dishes easily
cooked issues isn't a cooked like steaks
with Chimi Jura and how resa roasted
sweet potatoes or your favorite sun basket
recipe.
Sun Basket works cause I kind of
did an offensive Asian accent there.
I have to do something
else here. Uh, or ray good.
Tony was the sun basket works with the
best fam farms and suppliers to bring you
fresh, organic produce.
Wild caught seafood.
Just pictured the fish making like a
horse sound right as you're pulling it out
of the sea and responsibly
raised meats. Hey, hey,
knock it off all of you
cows. It's bedtime. Okay.
Plus Sun basket is delivered in perfect
portions with reliable nutrition.
I said knock it off. You go over,
you apologize to that other cow.
I'm not having Cadillac this. Do
you understand me? Plus Sun Basket.
I said Sun basket is delivered in
perfect portions with reliable nutrition
information and it's ready to
a whip up in about 30 minutes.
How do you responsibly raised me that
that's a big, that's a wide, you know,
it's a big vague statement.
There's something for every fiscally
responsibly or responsible to the cow.
There's something for
every healthy journey.
Like what do you say to the cow right
before you kill it. You know what I mean?
Hey Man, look at that over there.
Okay. I've always loved you. Uppercut.
There's something for every healthy
journey and with every business lifestyle,
go to sun basket.com/burr,
but you are to learn more and
get $35 off your first order.
That's sun basket.com/burr for
$35 off sun basket.com/burr.
There you go. There you go. And
that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast. Uh,
I hope all of you have
a responsible weekend,
a response, and you have a
responsibly raised child with, uh,
all your fiscal earnings in their
proper a ledger or something.
I have no idea. All right,
have a great weekend.
You Con Bruins verse the Florida Panthers
Tonight. Maybe there'll be some fights.
And, um, this weekend I'm going
to be up and outside of a,
I'm in Landcaster,
Ontario with Joe Barton,
nick the Rosebowl tailgate legend
Joe Barden, Nick and Paul Vert, Paul.
I know everything that happens in
aviation. Versie in other words,
anytime there's a crash, he
reads up on, by the way, man. Um,
that was a horrific helicopter crash in,
uh,
in New York City. Of course, I've
been paying attention to that. And uh,
this quick footage of the guy landing
the helicopter and he looks like he
totally, he totally fucking nailed it. Um,
the landing wasn't hard at all and
he got out and nobody else did.
And I think from what I'm
hearing in her circles is a,
they were flying with doors off. So,
not only did they have the seat belts,
which are,
I think they're the,
the the four ones that connect with the
circle in the middle, which you also,
you had to turn it like clockwise or
counterclockwise cause I was thinking that
they panicked and didn't know how to,
you know, the once they land like, fuck,
I'm in a helicopter crash and then
all fuck, I don't want to drown in.
Like I remember I went skydiving and um,
I did a static line jumps.
So there was nobody attached to me.
And um,
I remember it was awkward towels and
thousand two, 1003 1000, 4,000 look,
if nothing,
look reached pulse.
So when you pulled your emergency ripcord
you had to talk your way through it,
look to see it reached, to grab
it, pull to pull the thing.
Cause other than you'd be panicking and
flailing starting to do somersaults and
shit. So I thought maybe
that was it. But, um,
someone was saying to me that they were
possibly flying doors off and as an
extra safety precaution,
they had them hooked to the helicopter
with one of those c clamp type of job.
He's there and there's
two different kinds.
There's the one that's the quick release,
um,
and then as the extra extra one that you,
you screw on.
Um,
and uh,
they were suggesting that it was probably
that one and that even if they got
this seat belts on that
they were, uh, I dunno,
basically strapped to the helicopter
and went down and drowned.
I have no idea of how
fucking horrific is that.
Why would I end the podcast on that? I
have no idea. I have no fucking evidence.
That's just what's been suggested to
me. So anyways, on that upbeat note,
Ah, listen to, uh,
some happy music now and then
we'll go into some greatest hits.
I don't know why I talked to, you
know, why cause I in that made me
scared.
Yeah,
maybe happy to see that the guy
fucking totally landed at like a stud.
And then if what is being suggested
happened actually happened,
I would can't imagine the pilot,
you know,
having to deal with those
five fucking people. You know,
they're going to try to fucking blame him.
It,
cause it seems like that's one of those
things where they made it so safe that
they didn't,
they created another fucking problem,
which means they'll probably then have
some sort of new clamp that they design.
I don't fucking know. Anyways. Uh,
how do I talk my way out of this?
I have no idea. I'm sitting here,
uh, just flailing. All right.
Listen to the fucking music
and have a great weekend.
You conch and there'll be another half
hour greatest hits where hopefully I don't
and that's such a gloomy.
Nope.
Wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 16th, 2010. How the hell are you?
How's it going? It's a daylight savings
time if you haven't figured it out yet.
If you're wondering why you keep
being late for the last 24 hours.
It's actually Sunday when I'm doing
this thing because, uh, you know,
I get sick of people on the
east coast bitching dude,
you should call it [inaudible] to
move fucking Monday afternoon podcast.
Should I um,
I respect that you want to get to work?
Do you want to begin fucking off
immediately start your week off, right.
I understand. So I tape them on
Sundays now when I can and uh,
hope you guys all had a good weekend.
My Sunday started great.
My dog puked on the floor after,
you know,
three days of threatening dry
heaves and every time we go out,
walk up the street, the things
eating grass like it's a goddamn cow.
And my girls always going, stop
it. Stop it. Stop eating the grass,
stamp it.
And uh,
I vaguely remember overhearing
someone who I hope new,
a veterinarian who said something to
the effect that a animals eat grass when
they're not feeling well. So last night
I was taking her out late at night,
right at that, that critical fucking
moment to scary moment. My neighborhood.
All right. There's a
moment where, uh, you know,
when you're in a bad
part of the city and uh,
there's that moment around dusk
where all the decent, hardworking,
honest people are coming in
after a nice decent, honest,
hardworking days pay,
you know,
is they try to get out kind of like
a good times episode, you know,
and then there's, there's that point where
then the scumbags come out, you know,
who are doing all kinds of illegal shit,
which I don't even know what the fuck
to even think about that anymore.
Now it's just as fucked up.
I was going to say, you know,
it was fucking crooked is he's
God damn banks are, you know,
is selling drugs. Yes it is. It is
just as fucking bad. So anyways,
just stay on.
I'm already off fucking track.
You know what my fucking bank did to me.
I walked in,
I had this account in New
York that I kind of a,
it was a little checking account that
had a little bit of money in and all of a
sudden I noticed they would taking
some fees out. I'm like, well,
that shouldn't be. So I
get to New York, I walk in,
I talked to the Douche bag who
works there and he goes, yeah,
they're taking $27 a month
out. I Dunno why that is. Here,
let me check to see what's up. Click
and collect. I'll check on his thing.
And he goes, yeah, we shouldn't have
been doing that. And I go, okay,
well can you refund the money? And
they go, absolutely. A, and I go, well,
well you know,
I've had the account for like six years.
Can we see how long you've been doing
this? And he's like, oh, I'm sorry.
Are Our records only go
back for four months? Um,
really it only goes back for four months.
It's amazing because my bank records at
home go back the entire time I've had
the account.
That's incredible.
And I just have some piddly summon
there while you deal with hundreds of
millions of dollars, if not
billions, if not trillions.
I don't know what the fuck you have.
I just know there's a fucking Bank
of yours in every God damn state now.
But of course it only goes back like
four months. So I go, all right,
well what if I bring my records in?
I look them over and I find out how long
you've been doing it. And they're like,
Nah, he can only refund it for
four months. I'm like, dude,
what are you talking
about? And he goes, well,
the bank kind of looks at it like that,
that that was on you.
And I was like,
it's on me to not to not be like paying
attention to make sure the people who
supposed to be keeping my money safe
aren't fucking stealing from me.
And he sort of like laughed.
I'm like, dude, this isn't
funny. This is ridiculous.
You guys just from me. And if you've
been doing it for six years, what's that?
270 bucks?
Add another fucking Nav.
50 like almost 300 bucks
a year for six years.
That's like 1500 to 1800
bucks somewhere in there.
And the guy's just sitting there
fucking laughing and uh, you know,
this is a usual shit guy. What
are you gonna Sue us? Go ahead.
We'll take some of that bailout money,
which is part of your tax
money and we'll fucking, uh,
so I don't know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to close out the account and uh,
and I don't know.
What do I do then I go across the street
to one of the bat for banks that are
left.
If anybody out there is in banking,
how do I get my money back
beyond the four months?
Cause I know that they've been
doing it longer than this. Um,
can anybody explain that?
You know, this is why people,
this is why you don't put 100% of
your paycheck into the fucking bag.
He got to look at it this way.
If somebody mugged you last week,
would you walk up to the same person
and take your paycheck and stick it in
their back pockets? You
wouldn't, would you?
But for some reason we have these
fucking bankers. Yeah. I don't know.
I think everybody should turn like,
I dunno,
everybody should have a fucking safe
that you have buried somewhere. Yeah,
everybody's got a gun in. Anybody
can blow anybody away. I know.
It's all fucked up.
Fucking assholes.
You guys sitting there fucking smiling.
Nobody sitting there doing,
he's doing that little twirly thing.
You know that math people do with their
pens and people were into finances.
I think they do it to
hypnotize you and says,
the guy's fucking sitting there telling
me that they'd been stealing 30 bucks a
month from me and all I'm doing
is I'm trying to focus on him.
I keep looking down at his silver
shiny pen, some sort of mind trick.
Fortunately, I was aware
of it. How am I said,
can you stop twirling your fucking pen?
But I didn't want to do that cause
I was trying to keep my cool,
which obviously is a difficult
thing for me to do. You know?
I don't know right now a pill.
It's just 27 bucks a month times how
many fucking people you remember superman
three when Richard Pryor stole half a
cent from everybody and the next day he
had a fucking Ferrari.
He's Fox had taken 27 bucks a month
from everybody. I'm convinced of it.
That's the fucking mob.
I swear to God the mob went legit
or those there will be blood guys.
They're the fucking assholes
and run the Goddamn bags.
He's fucking constant just stealing
from me and there's nobody getting,
nobody's going to help me.
What am I going to go down there?
I'm going to get that guy used to be
on the fucking, uh, leave it to beaver.
What the fuck was the name of that show?
A Mayberry. I always hated that show,
that old content walking around with
their false set of voice earned.
You know, you know what that show
lacked somebody that I wanted to bang.
That's why I didn't watch it.
There was nobody fuckable on it.
That was the brilliance of the
monsters that they were like,
this is going to be hilarious.
We're gonna turn fucking Frankenstein
into DRAC and Dracula into these Kooky
characters and it's all going to be funny.
But they knew at the end of the day
they had to be somebody that the male
demographic would want to fuck.
So they came up with that
girl who was allegedly ugly.
Why am I explaining this classic show?
You know the deal and she looked like
Marilyn Monroe and that's what kept me in
there. I Dunno. All right.
Batman after a while it's like to what
is going on with this 40 year old guy in
his ward?
Okay.
And then all of a sudden they had cat
woman walking around that fucking hoary
outfit.
Is she the one who started that shit?
Did women not dress like horrors on uh,
on Halloween before Batman
are a bad girl or cat woman?
Catwoman was a bad one,
right?
Okay.
This such pathetic cons,
you know what I mean? It's,
we take off that fucking
ridiculous outfit.
Go stand behind a wall and, and, and
start talking to people in the store.
How many people even fucking
pay attention to you?
They don't cause you got nothing to say.
All you can do is just dress up your God
damn Twat and starts strutting around
the fucking place.
That had nothing to do with Catwoman.
Had nothing to do with her.
I had to do with me fucking getting fucked
over by that God damn bag, assholes,
fucking assholes.
And I go to down there,
I got to go down and I like to like some
fucking guy who's buttoned store just
failed after 75 years,
you know,
Frankie fish face and sons
remember those fucking um,
those businesses when you were a kid.
Okay.
It was always something
something and sons.
Yeah.
You know, and like a lot of the times
the kids were forced into the business.
Okay.
Yeah. I'm Italian guy. He opens a fucking
prosciutto shop and then that's it.
It's like an arranged marriage except
that your job and then you got to show up.
I have been working in the restaurants
and that was the day that, you know,
they don't know shit about anything else.
Does.
Everybody wanted to strike
out on their own and now look,
everybody ends up in a fucking cubicle
worker for these fucking cunts was
stealing my money. That's
uplifting isn't it? Um, anyways,
this is the Monday morning
podcast and it's on my website.
I'm trying to get it onto iTunes.
I'm in between web guys right now.
Hopefully this is up on iTunes.
We worked on it yesterday. Um,
you know,
and it was weird.
It was up on my web guys computer
but it wasn't up on my computer.
So if you're listening
to this on my website,
maybe you go to iTunes and you
just hold down the shift button.
I mean maybe iTunes just keeps
reloading a, you know how it,
it remembers a page that you've been to.
So when you go back to it a load quicker,
hold down the shift button.
When you're on that page, um, I believe
that then you can see the new one.
So now I have three podcasts.
Okay.
Fucking ridiculous. But eventually
we're going to get it all under one.
This is the first time I've ever had a
web guy who lives down the street from me.
Um,
I have new video up on my
website and buy new video.
I mean video that actually works.
And um,
this is part of a whole new revamping
that I've tried to do like 10 times.
I know I've always promised that, but, um,
I'm going to be uploading video to my
website and to start video my video taping
myself out on the road, putting up little
bullshit things up there. You know,
the usual bullshit. Give you guys
a couple of crumbs every week.
So you still give a fuck about me.
So when I come to your town,
maybe you'll buy a ticket for you
and your best little girl or fucking
boyfriend, whatever you got going on out
there, whatever it is that you do. Um,
there's also a fan page for the
Monday morning podcast. Now, uh,
www.themmpodcast.com.
Uh,
there's questions, there's pictures.
I make references to fucked up stuff.
Like say you haven't watched the Munsters,
maybe there'll be a picture of the
hottie on the monsters, you know,
so, uh, and that's it.
My girlfriend just walked in and then
tippy toed back out again and then
shrugged his shoulders like I wasn't
going to address it. You heard me,
I was in a lull.
So anyways,
I really apologize for the horror that
has been trying to find my podcast over
the last month or so.
Um,
I didn't think that it was going
to be such a big deal, you know.
Uh,
I,
I just thought I could just switch over
to a new server server and it wasn't
going to be a problem, but evidently
it's this major fucking deal.
And I've talked to other podcasters out
there and they were talking about what a
fucking pain in the ass it is to get it
up on iTunes because once you do get it
up on iTunes, then they have to
approve of it as if to say yes,
this is in fact a podcast and
beyond that we approve of it.
So anyways, Jesus Christ, it's
already one in the afternoon.
I just went out to brunch with my lovely
girlfriend and I heard some fucking,
oh my God, that goes back to my
joke. You really go to a branch to,
did somebody have pes? Um, yeah.
Went down to this fucking place and
we're hanging out down there and uh,
this fucking dude, um, I
don't know if he was gay,
but he had the gay accent,
which is always fun to me.
Like there's a part of the
country that they're from,
which is an old joke that I used to do.
Um,
he was talking about daylight savings
times. He was just like, oh my God.
Like this is how it should be all
the time. You know, it's like,
this is Los Angeles,
this whole getting out of work at five
and it's dark out. It's just like,
what is going on with that?
That's like one of those things ever.
Just hear somebody like that.
There's like such a fucking cliche
that whoever you're with, you just,
you're just sort of
staring down at your food.
And then when you look at the person that
you're with, you don't move your head.
You just slowly look up at each other
and then all of a sudden it's like you're
in grade school again.
And there was a teacher said,
the next person who fucking
laughs is getting detention.
It's one of those moments.
It was tight quarters so we couldn't like
really start laughing at them. But, um,
I really wanted to lean over and be like,
you know,
part of the reason why it's so fucking
dark out during the wintertime is the
whole planet, the northern hemisphere
tilts away from the sun there. Fuck face.
All right, so even in December, it
would probably.be dark around five.
Despite the time change. Actually maybe
it would maybe more like five 45 30,
depending on where you're at.
Right. I mean, am I ignorant?
Of course I am, but as far as I know,
daylight savings is the bullshit time.
Like right now it's not
really one o'clock. We're
just saying it's one o'clock.
So the farm hands out in the Midwest can
have more fucking time to harvest the,
uh, the beans made out of corn
products according to Food Inc. Right.
I don't fucking know. I have no idea
what they do and I just fucking,
why do I have to,
I,
every week I talk about shit that
I don't know anything about it.
It's the funniest shit.
Like I, I go into it,
I start getting anxiety cause I know
I don't know what I'm talking about.
So why would I literally try to
do is I try to use like momentum.
Like maybe if I say something dumb
quickly, no one's gonna notice.
I believe that that's exactly what
it is in my world. That made sense.
So on to today's topics,
I was all excited to wake up this
morning and watch the Chicago Blackhawks
against the Washington capitals.
Why may you ask? I'll tell you why.
Because I love the sport of hockey and a,
it's a good chance that those two teams
could possibly meet in the finals,
if not in the finals next year.
The two teams that are right there.
All right?
And everybody always bitches out of
hockey sticks and they always blame the
fighting. They got to get the fighting
out of the fucking game. All right?
That's why nobody watches it.
Well,
I'm going to give you an example of the
NHL here. This is what they do today.
Okay?
During the week,
my Bruins played the Pittsburgh
penguins and a overall,
Pittsburgh's a decent franchise
for respectable. I respect them,
but they always didn't seem to
have one douche bag on the team.
The off Samuelson, you know the guy
who just can't fucking play, you know,
he can't play,
he can't fucking fight.
He can't even just skate around and
annoy you like a Ken Lindeman back in the
day. So what he does is he goes out there
and he basically tries to end people's
careers or their seasons and
that's what he did to mark Savara.
I even know the fucking guys name and
I don't even want to know his name.
Kind of like somebody goes up and
shoots up a fucking mall so they can get
famous. I always make sure I
don't remember the fucking name,
even though the news can't
stop talking about him.
So this fucking cunt just basically
glides in after survivor took shot.
Granted if he hit his body, it was
a legal hit, but he didn't, he took,
he took his shoulder slash elbow and just
blasted him right in the fucking head.
And he's so only connected with his
head that Savara literally helicoptered
around and landed down on the ice.
And not only was he not suspended or fine,
there wasn't even a penalty.
I Dunno what it is about the penguins.
For some reason,
they always have that one goon who can
go in and just blow out Cam Neeley's
fucking knee.
And then his career,
that guy just ended Savardi fucking season
or one goal scorer and they then they
do nothing.
Told the whole hockey world is
flipping out like, dude, what the fuck?
So what do they do to make it up today?
Washington capitals versus
the Chicago Blackhawks there.
One nationally televised
game this week on NBC.
You can actually watch it in HD TV.
So while you fucking idiots out
there who can't see the Puck,
I can't fear where is it? I
can't see it. Fucking black.
Object against the white surface.
Can't fucking see it.
Why don't you start with looking at the
guy that everybody appears to be mad at
on the other team? You
know, start with that guy.
Maybe that's the guy who has the
object that they desire. So anyways,
you know what they do?
They ended up kicking fucking Ovechkin.
They gave him a game misconduct out of
the game because he did some halfway.
I mean, it was a check that deserved a
penalty possibly of fucking double minor,
and they kicked the best player in the
league out of the fucking game on their
national telecast.
And I'm a tell you right now.
Well that is why that is
why nobody watches hockey,
because they continually make
moves like that. I don't know why.
Every five years they get back on ESPN
and then they go, oh, wait a minute,
the USA network is offering us $5 more,
or let's go over there.
Let's go over to the versus
network.
How many people you think
would be watching the NFL if
throughout the years they,
you know,
they occasionally for three years would
disappear onto like the learning channel.
You know what I mean? It really has
nothing to do with the fighting.
It's such a stupid fucking comment
that people make and it's hypocritical.
If you truly feel that that fighting
should be out of that game as much as the
whole world enjoys violence.
We love violence.
Go on Youtube and look at the
fucking ones that get the most hits.
We like to laugh and we'd like
to watch somebody get fucked up.
That's what I've learned
from going onto youtube. Oh.
And people or we'll find a way to uh,
talk politics or discuss race on
any video that you stick up there.
And speaking of that, um, dude,
I was so fucking bummed out.
I woke up an hour late so I missed the
first period and then I find out a vet
can isn't even fucking plague and it was
laying down. And next thing you know,
they Chicago scores, it's three nothing.
And the game is basically over for the,
or for those of you who don't watch
hockey three, nothing is basically, uh,
I would, it's like being down
17 points and football. Yeah,
sometimes 21, depending on how
bad your fucking team is. So, um,
I was upset as a hockey fan.
I still love the Nhl and I still
think you guys should watch the game.
I was actually watching a little bit of
the Premier League because I'm going to
Europe this week and uh,
the excitement of that has finally hit me.
I'm not excited about the
17 hour or whatever it is,
15 hour flight from Los Angeles.
But um,
I'm beyond excited to go over there and
have killer shows and to begin to build
a following over there
because a cause why not?
Because you only go around once.
I was going to get a tour of the
fucking Abbey road studios and that fell
through. So now I don't know what to
do. I don't know what to do over there.
And for those of you who
haven't been on my website
this week,
on Thursday,
I am playing at the Lester
theatre in London, England.
How fucking cool does that sound?
Then I'm playing the sugar club in uh,
in uh,
Dublin Ireland on Friday.
And then the next night I go to Glasgow,
Scotland.
A lot of you Americans like me,
you are going to want to say glass.
Gow cause it looks like it's
written like slow, you know, low.
But it's Gow glass cow, uh, Scotland.
And I actually don't even know the fucking
name of the theater I'm playing there,
but uh, it's gonna be awesome
and I am coming off the wagon.
My Good Buddy Joe to
Rosa went 70 days sober,
so I had to beat him because I'm a
competitive fuck and I was going to take
myself off last night.
It's 71 days, you know,
kind of like a nod to Roger
Maris 60 home runs 61 70 71.
But I decided fuck it. You know, if I'm
going to fall off the fucking wagon,
it's going to be in a pub in a London,
England. That's when I'm going to do it.
So I need you English people to tell me
where there's a good pup and by a good
pub.
I don't meet some loud fucking bar
with a bunch of douchebags in it,
trying to act like they're cooler than
they really are. I want some fucking,
I want some place I could walk in that's
a little bit quieter but I'm not going
to get the shit kicked out of me once
they realize I'm an American. Okay,
I need to know that.
I also need to know if I bring DVDs over
there to sell to you guys for pounds,
euros, whatever the fuck
you're on. I believe you guys,
you guys haven't accepted the
euro, but I think Ireland has, um,
I need to know the DVDs,
play the American code version,
whatever the fucking technical term is.
Do those things play over there?
Are they formatted correctly?
Cause I don't want to go over there
and sell you guys a bunch of shit that
doesn't work. And then
we got to, you know,
then I'm like a bank and
then I got to be like,
well you know that's
really on you get home.
She should have realized that
I was from America and uh,
I have a different fucking DVD system
than you do. So there you go. My, sorry,
my records only go back four minutes.
I really don't have any recollection
of going over there. So anyways,
I don't know what else to do over
there. John Bonham's grave, you know,
maybe I'll go see that.
Um,
what else could I do?
I don't want to go do that Douchey Shit.
Guy Glow Look Big Ben and parliament.
I don't wanna I don't wanna look
at that stuff. I want to, uh,
I don't want, I want to do, I want to walk
around and want to look at Sim. Who is,
I want to do what? People in
London, England. Dope that right.
That's what I want to do.
Which is what?
Eat Indian food right after a
plate full of fish and chips. Um,
I dunno what the fuck
you guys do over there,
but if you could tell me some stuff
to do. I know stone chat, Stonehenge,
I've talked to enough Americans
who've gone over there.
It's basically sitting on the side
of the road like a fucking Starbucks.
It's very underwhelming. Um,
whenever they film it there,
they're real close and
they make sure that,
that they don't have the highway like 10
feet away from the fucking thing. I'm,
I can't wait for somebody to fall asleep
at the wheel and just drive right into
that thing.
That's going to be hilarious.
So anyways,
this is the podcast this week.
I had been kind of Cunty the last couple
of weeks I've been in a bad move, but,
uh, I'm in a much better
mood this week, so, uh,
I don't know if that'll make this less
funnier or more tolerable. It's up to you.
So here's some youtube videos.
Speaking of England, uh,
this is my nod to,
uh,
just something I discovered
a few years ago, um,
through this comedian Jordan Rubin.
I was the one on is my space page.
Remember that? You remember my
space? I was the last one. Um,
he had a clip of this on his page
and I actually checked it out.
It's called the Prince of Wales. And, uh,
it's actually spelled w,
h a l e s, like the, uh,
the mammal and a, it's
called Derek and Clive, d.
R e c o s r d e r e.
K. And Clive Cli. V. E. Alright.
And it's actually Dudley
Moore and this Guy Peter Cook,
who most Americans have never heard of.
And um,
it's basically just imagine if I was
doing a podcast with some other asshole,
but 30 years ago and it's this,
just them going off on stuff and they
made, when you watch the clip, it stem,
I believe,
recording the album and it was just the
most filthiest shit and offensive stuff
that they could come up. They talk
about religion, a lot of stuff,
a lot of stuff that actually, I was
watching it and I was like, Jesus Christ,
this is a,
this is like the original podcast.
It's completely over the top
and a, I guess, you know,
it's Dudley Moore and that Peter Cook
and I guess they were supposed to be a,
I don't know what they was supposed
to be mean. I don't live over there,
so obviously, so I don't know
what, who they're supposed to be.
I'm just imagining it's just a couple
of cans. Kevin and I can sit in a bar.
I don't know what, but it's fucking
hilarious to me and I hope you enjoy it.
All right. I have also,
by the way, I have a nice,
I have a nice variety of youtube videos.
So if you're not into the comedy thing,
if you want to see a beautiful woman with
the most killer body I've ever seen in
my fucking life and an accent to match
it and her hair done up and fucking pony
tails as she works out.
Look up fitness, uh,
killer five 50 rep workout fitness
dash killer five 50 workout.
Uh,
I can't remember the name of the girl.
She's ridiculous and she does this
insane workout. She's in shape,
I believe her titties or natural,
unless you went to Dallas and got those
teardrop fucking fake ones that I saw
out there.
Um,
and she just works out and she looks
unbelievable and as she gets further into
the set,
she starts going like,
it's fucking awesome. Um, and a comedian,
you should checkout, checkout out.
Reggie watts are
[inaudible] watts, w a t. T.
S a lot of the shitty puts up.
There was this musical stuff that he does,
I think because he doesn't want to
burn as material like most comedians.
But if you get a chance to see that guy,
there you go recommending a
video and in a comedian, um,
those are all on youtube. And
here's another, the last video.
I will recommend this something,
a break.com and there's something
called the tree terminator.
And uh,
it's just one of those
machines that you're going to
see that it just shows that
human beings were just too fucking
smart for our own God. Damn good.
Basically this machine, for those of you
who are on a treadmill right now, it just
each has, it's like a big hand.
I Dunno what it is. It just,
it looks like a back haul,
but it's really like a hand in,
it just grabs these trees,
pulls them right out of the ground and
then it like, imagine if like, okay, you,
you fucking, you threw a
jab, right. Do that right
now when your cubicle several one thinks
you're fucking insane and they're just
waiting and have a fist so they don't
think you're fucking listening to her
Hitler video. Um, stick. Yeah.
Sticky hand out there like you're
about ready to salute Hitler,
but have a fist so you
don't offend anybody.
And then just imagine if if your arm right
down to your wrist wouldn't move yet.
Your fucking hand could do an entire
fucking three 60 that's what this device
does except you're holding a tree
and then what it does is it fucking,
some are holds the tree in place with,
I dunno what some device in there and
then it loosens its grip and it goes up
and down the tree.
Like it's jacking it off horizontally.
But what it's really doing is removing
all the branches and the leaves.
So then all you're left
with is the fucking is the
trunk with the bark still on
it. It gives it another fucking
Jack and now it's you know,
back and forth a few times now all it is
is just as round spool of a of wood and
then add, it doesn't stop there.
Then it goes all the way down to the,
I guess where the balls would be.
Right? It's very fucking a phallic here.
And then what it starts
where the weather at,
the base of the shaft goes up about three
and then tramp that was supposed to be
at slicing and half. I really
fucking blew it on that. Uh,
that was the worst sound effect ever.
Clamp. That's not what he doesn't want.
That's what it did. That's the
right sound effects. Say No.
Michael Winslow this week and
the edge just in sections, like little
fucking six foot sections of wood.
And I'm telling you it can do it.
One tree every like 20 seconds.
And this guy's just a one mic.
One guy with a machine is just basically
going through this forest so we can all
have baseball bats. I don't know what,
just you know, button an amount of time.
It took me to fucking explain that. You
could have looked it up and watched it.
It was such an idiot. What am I
got to hear? What's coming up next?
What's the next subject here on
the Monday morning podcast? Oh,
here's something it's called,
let's get smart is an
exclamation ex explanation point.
I'm desperately trying to become a,
uh,
the smartest more on that I can become
an I've actually through that Lumosity.
Dot.
And becoming a better speller.
And these are some of
the words that I've been,
one of the Games I've been
trying to come up with,
but I don't know how to
spell them. So then I, uh,
I just write them down and I give myself
spelling tests, aesthetic aggressive,
allege bizarre Catamaran,
cantaloupe, catalyst, catalyst,
chloroform, disingenuous, facetious.
You know,
you know what's great about,
these are all words that
you can use in print,
but if you actually use them a while
speaking, you come off like a douchebag,
at least in the circle of
people that I'm hanging out,
like who we're hanging out with that
can't use the word infrastructure.
Can I use the word melancholy?
Huh? Anybody else spell
melancholies to spell it?
M E. L. L. O. N. K. O.
L. L. Y. Like I did,
I wasn't that bad, but it was
pretty brutal. Like succinct.
I was playing this game.
And uh, you have to do that.
Like when you're texting and you come
up with a word that you so can't even
spell, like your brain literally
locks and lights succinct.
I was like,
how the fuck do you spell this?
Saw as a
saint.
Is that like sync? Like you
brush your teeth? S I. N, k, e. D
you know the past tense of sync. Sinked
or like sync something up. See why.
See I think I spelled s u s y c and
then laughed and hit enter and then the
computer's like, oh mom,
did you mean succinct?
You know, you know when Google
gets all country like that.
Oh my believe when you were
trying to say was really,
I believe we fucking made you.
That might've been my girl.
Just laughed at me.
What Neil was that one of the dumbest
things I've ever said on this that was
pretty fucking stupid.
Yeah.
I believe we made you,
you know,
in 30 years when I lead the rebellion
against the robots that are, uh,
that, that are going
to replace us, that's,
that's are going to be our battle
cry when we're sitting there
with our p nine dx bodies and I'll be
standing there getting a sunburn just
standing there with half
a blue face going, ohm.
I believe we made you
don't move.
Don't move until their screen shuts down.
That's the lights of their eyes,
like giving you attitude. It does
have an APP. Well, come over here.
You're going to be on the podcast.
It does have an attitude. Oh,
it says to help you
out. No, but it's said.
Yeah, it is. Well, you know something,
I guess it all depends on the voice
in your head. Cause did you mean this?
The only thing it's missing it, it should
just have o.dot, dot. In front of it.
What the fuck was that? Yeah,
you're supposed to continue.
That just made it sound like it. Bob,
do you want, yeah. All right. Move on.
Where are you going?
You're a little Russian mail order bride
that you watch on youtube there. Oh,
how hard is she? You gotta admit
she's hot. She's very hot. What'd you,
what I would make out with her
answering that question. It's a yes.
See fucking champ right here.
Fucking champ.
Maybe we'll see her when
we're over there and uh,
pull ups in some war torn country,
which he's on the head
when she's on that route.
When she's on that rooftop and she's
doing all her squat thrusts and making
noises like a porno star, doesn't she
look like she's in the middle of like,
they just bomb. First of all,
she's, she's tired after her set.
She's tired after
you fucking talking about it.
That's what I'm tired of.
So what do you think about that?
I think that brings it full circle to me.
Have an attitude about Google.
I didn't ask you to only know
it's going to put it up there.
Why can't I enjoy one of God's
beautiful creatures? Police
fucking break. Fuck you. Every time
you see Kevin Garnett on the screen,
you got to make that fucking, yeah, yeah.
See, go fuck yourself. Get out of here.
Can I see your breath for a second?
He just said, get out. Get Out.
Beat it. You have to
leave in 20 minutes. Well,
call a cab sweetheart.
You know what? Nothing.
Don't get that Google attitude with me.
Oh,
I have to leave in 20 minutes.
No one's stopping you.
Hey Nia. How do you spell succinct
if you're so fucking smart.
Cause I told you how to spell it the other
day. Fuck you. Shut up. Shut your face.
Watch what don't I listen?
What succinct as
I e. N. Z. Ah, you know it isn't.
Can I tell you something?
This is when you know you
don't know how to spell a word.
When for some reason you're looking the
right or left and there's nobody there.
You don't know how to spell it.
The UCC.
I. E. N. S. U. C. C. I. N. C. T. Succinct.
There's no e. No, that's
a hard one. Facetious.
It's like face Sacious,
right? Like how you say it?
F A. Oh my God, I can't breathe with you.
We're going to have a dumbest kid ever.
Yeah,
it's a baby boy. Boy. Oh, well,
it'll go. That's why it has school
and teachers for dumb parents.
Did you just say that's why
it has school and teachers?
Do you see what cell phones are
doing to us? I'm telling you.
That's why it good Lord. Would you
look at you? Wow. All right. Anyways,
that's why they make a beautiful,
you just bombed the spelling test.
Wow.
You're not a good speller. Really? Well,
that was a too difficult. Okay.
Facetious. His face tee os, fac.
E. T. I. O. U s. So I'm actually
sitting here. I'm like a psycho,
like a Jack Nicholson in the shining and
I'm just sitting here writing sentences
that don't really make any sense because
I just want to use all the words that
I've used that I've learned.
I mean,
the mallow tourist melancholy of the
psychotic critics was aesthetically
pleasing despite their silhouette,
the capitulation of the
inmates penitentiary argument
could be stated that one
doesn't need and as squiz
exquisite repertoire,
merely a succinct dilemma with a
sociopath. Nice fucking restaurant.
Sorry,
I ran out of words.
I just remember all I had left
was restaurant and I was like,
I need one more sentence and I was tired.
One of a fuck you,
you spell some of those words.
But I'm saying like I'm just listen to
how I speak. Okay. And how many words?
I mispronounce it.
I've lied to myself for years.
That the reason why I make such a fool
of myself is because my brain works so
quickly that it, it's, it's,
it's ahead of where my tongue is at and
then that's not fucking true. All right.
I'm here to tell you that
I am an idiot and I'm,
I'm really trying desperately to,
uh,
I've come to the acceptance that
I'm a moron and if I can, I just,
but I just want it be,
but I still don't feel even,
I still feel like I can at least
improve on. Uh, I can be kicked by big.
I can become less of a moron.
All right.
So this is basically what I've been doing.
As I've been saying in
the past couple of weeks,
I've been writing with my right hand cause
I'm lefthanded and I've been throwing
with my left hand because I do sports with
my right hand, my fucking mess. But um,
yeah, I guess it opens
different parts of your brain.
And I was talking about it and
sounding like a moron is always,
um, how do you spell cantaloupe
as a good one? Huh? You know,
cantaloupe, we know those
days when you're like, ah,
I got to get in shape yet you still go
out for breakfast and you still get the
pancakes and the eggs,
but you go, you know what,
I'm not going to get the home fries. Let
me get a fruit cup instead. You know?
And then they have that look
on their face like, holy shit,
nobody orders the Fruit Cup. That's why
I forgot it was even on the fucking menu.
And then they go out there and they bring
this Fruit Cup bought back out to you.
Right. And it's always
that little, uh, you know,
he's got a couple of grapes.
It's got a melon and this got cantaloupe.
And it has little fucking moldy tentacles
reaching to each piece of fruit.
Cantaloupe.
I love cantaloupe.
A lot of people don't know that about
myself and a for the life of me,
I couldn't spell it.
I spelled it like,
like cantaloupe. Like you cantaloupe,
you have to have a wedding.
This is how,
this is how he spelled c a n t a l o u.
P. E if I haven't bored you to
fucking tears at this point,
nothing I'll talk about. Well
let's move on to the next one. Um,
so basically I was talking
about that stuff where you,
you actually use your opposite
hand. It all started with this, uh,
some comic down the comedy store can't
move the fuck it was because my brain's
mush was talking about how that improves
your brain and actually if you're
lefthanded and use your right hand for
stuff that usually use with your left
hand and actually improves your lefthand
allegedly. So this gets scientist,
I'm going to call him a scientist rights.
And he said, Bill and your podcast,
when you talk about using your opposite
hand and learning to write with it,
the term is called neuroplasticity
or Blain plasticity.
I don't know how the fuck
to say, uh, what are,
what you are doing is
retraining your brain.
That's the science behind brain fitness.
Here is a nice little article about
it on a p o s I t science.com.
Um, and actually, you know something,
I've actually seen someone who
did something like that. Uh,
every morning me and my lovely
girlfriend go for this hike.
And when we first moved out here,
there was this guy who clearly just had
a stroke and he would walk up the hill.
He was walking like, well, I'm
talking to serious like hike here.
And this guy was going like, you
know, a half, not even a half a mile,
quarter of a mile an hour.
I was almost going to say a
half a mile every two hours.
And I quickly did the math. See, I'm
getting smarter and stop laughing at me.
So, um, I like this. I like you coming
in and out of the room laughing.
So I know that you kind of like a little
mini studio audience so I know that at
least some of this is funny.
So anyways,
this fucking guy is walking with a cane
and it's one of those deals where you
like, there's no way he's
going to make it up to the top.
And every morning we would see this guy,
you know,
if we'd left at the same time and then
we go a couple of weeks we wouldn't see
him. And he just kept getting
better and better and better.
And the how unbelievable did that guy
look the last time it was his arm and all
straightened out,
his left leg was working again.
Somebody should have made a documentary
about that cause that's the part of the
movie where we would have been
crying as opposed to being like,
oh I haven't seen her a couple
weeks. You welcome. Great.
If you're going to talk,
come over towards the microphone.
I was saying we were with my
mom when we saw him. Right.
And how did that add to the story?
See,
this is why women's stink
at telling stories. Yeah,
but paint, but paint the story
about the thing that we're seeing.
My mother was there and I saw a
Robin right next to a squirrel.
So anyways, using your
opposite hand, he's just like,
what the fuck are you talking
about? You know what, Nia,
just sit there and look pretty.
Awe. All right. Um, so anyways,
if you guys, I'm telling
you the truth, um,
you can make yourself stroke proof that
stroke proof, but you can, you can,
you don't have to go through the Rehab.
Just blow the doctor's mind.
You know,
as you're writing a check
with your opposite hand for
how much they overcharged
you and you're already rubbing one out.
You're staring at your fucking, was
it bed nurse? Is that what it is?
Wet nurse. Whatever the fuck they,
ah, what nurses said breastfeeding.
Wasn't there something in the news
about breastfeeding this week?
Something about somebody who drinks
breastmilk and they're way beyond the age.
The John Mayer do another
interview for a Max.
You don't like John Mayer. He's a
fucking moron. He's not a fucking moron.
He's fucking okay.
What are you basing that on?
Everything that comes
out of his douche bag.
Give me an example.
That whole controversy
that came out recently,
the interview that he gave with
Playboy magazine, you know,
totally talking shit about everybody
and then maybe common. Wow.
First of all, it wasn't a controversy
really. Was it riding in the streets?
It was controversial.
He got on stage and started like fake
tearing up and apologizing to his fans and
being like,
I'm sorry I was trying to be clever.
I just thank you guys so much
for sticking by me and blah,
Blah Blah and all that. Wow. Yeah. He, he
went to, he had a tear
up about it. So Jesus,
I haven't seen, I haven't seen that
since Marlon Brando went off on the, uh,
went off on j town over there.
You don't remember that?
I already did that.
I got to keep it funny.
The end of his life. Yeah, he did
a little, he did wrote the, uh,
the prologue to the, uh, what's his
face? I will just say Martin Scorsese.
Melle Mel, not Mel Brooks.
Mel Gibson, his little rant.
Yeah,
and just this whole thing about how
a black people love him because he's,
what did he say? Cause I'm very, whatever
that means. And then the interviewer,
who admittedly I think asked to douchey
question that kind of set him up was
like, Oh, do black women throw
themselves at you? And he was like,
he said something like, yeah, but my
dick rejects them. Like I have a whites.
I have a United colors of Benetton
heart and a white supremacists Dick.
Yeah, but you can see how he's trying to
make a joke. He plays the Ukulele. Okay.
His comic timing is a little off.
You can see where he's going with that.
He knows what he likes. He knows what
he likes. He goes out and he tags it,
you know,
with his fucking updated mullet.
Look, if you've got to be on
coke, get another microphone.
If you're going to keep interjecting here.
I was trying to do a podcast.
You keep interrupting.
I've had enough of this joking.
You fucking control me with that
pouty face. It's fucking annoying. Um,
all right. Uh, recommending books
for the week. See us. Yeah, exactly.
What Oprah does it,
I can fucking do it,
but at least I have the honesty least I'm
honest enough to say I don't read them.
Nia, as you sit there and
looking into Oprah's eyes,
here's another wonderful
book that I didn't read,
but my intern said it was
great. I'm a book, uh, Bill,
I enjoy the podcast.
You have to check out a book called
the creature from Jekyll island.
It's a book about how the Federal Reserve
was started and they planned to be
able to have a system in place from the
start that would enable certain large
banks from being a,
from being bailed out if shit went down.
Apparently they've bailed out
banks before, just not a public.
Oh, that's fucking brilliant. So basically
they become the bank for all the banks.
And then what they do is they bail out
some of them every time they tank the
economy and some of them they don't.
And those things get consumed by the
other banks that exist and so on and so
forth. Just like, it's like
a reverse prowl commercial.
Instead of telling two
friends and so on and so on,
they're going the opposite direction all,
all the way towards a one World Bank,
which is why, what are we down to?
Now we're down to chase wells Fargo,
Bank of America,
and uh,
John Mellencamp trust it.
Doesn't he have one out there for the
farmers next to that little pink house?
Sage Jabil halls show. Don't
make it rain. Ethiopia.
All right.
Also,
you should look up a recent article in
Philadelphia about how more than a dozen
armed state police raided a few small
ale houses in Philly to confiscate in air
quotes,
unregistered beer.
They basically stole over seven
grand worth of pricey beer,
most of which was most of
which was actually registered,
but not accurately due to a clerical
errors made on the end of the city.
So it was the city's fall through. That's
fucking hilarious. I, that's bad. I know.
That's mean. They shouldn't be
doing that shit. But you know,
they stole beer. I mean, come on.
It's like Pauline and the
pope of Greenwich Village.
I didn't rape his daughter.
I didn't spit in his fat face. I
took money, Charlie fucking money.
They stole some bear, whatever.
They want to have a keg party.
And how are you going to do, all right,
here's one for you. I talked about the uh,
going to the cloud nine, a
titty bar in Troy, New York.
And there's actually an article on there
about this fucked up strip club that I
went to a number of years ago.
February 1st,
2008 CT police shut down the cloud
nine and adult entertainment business.
That's because they have
the video store next to it.
I believe that's out in the garage for
those of you didn't listen last week.
It's a,
it's a titty bar that you walk into and
it's like walking into somebody's house
and the second you walk in
there you want to leave.
But there's so few people in there.
They all look at you literally that moment
where the needle goes off the record
or the laser goes off
the CD or the iPod skips.
I don't know what the fuck to
say about nowadays, but um,
how to say it now for nowadays technology.
But anyways,
the city shut down the
cloud nine, uh, because uh,
this afternoon for multiple
code violations and charged
a 46 year old dancer,
a 46 year old dancer
with prostitution,
city officials said,
say that's for all you dancers out there.
That's what happens when you're in
your 20s. You can have an attitude,
but if you're 46 [inaudible] 46
years old and you still dancing,
you better drop to your fucking knees,
sweetheart, if you want to make the rent,
okay?
All the more reason to stop lying that
you're going to college and actually use
those fucking funny, that funny
money to go to college. All right.
Or you'll be working in the cloud
nine at 46. Wow. You know what?
I'm going to copy and paste that.
I'm going to print that sentence
and put it right above my desk.
Anytime I'm feeling bad about
my life, I'll be like, well,
at least I'm not a 46 year old
dancer charged with prostitution
at the, uh, cloud nine
to Troy New York. Uh,
the raid followed a five week
undercover investigation. Yeah.
How hilarious is that?
What were the undercover cop got blown
by the 46 year old in which Troy and,
um,
run Sealy,
our police officers observe dancers
engaged in elicit sexual activities.
Do this reeks of a shakedown. Like the
cops didn't know that was going on.
I did a college gig out there and
figured out what the fuck was going on in
about four hours.
What happened?
Did this 46 year old stop given
the free blow jobs to the cops,
speaking of which, you know,
I heard that asshole in the,
in the Prius who couldn't stop his
car. Um, you guys seen that story?
Um,
allegedly.
All that girls titties are fake by
the way. I'm looking at her right now.
The tits fake Nia. My fault. Wow.
That knocks her looks down by 40%.
I got to say, there's nothing,
there's nothing worse than fake tits.
It's just not,
that really just says
something about you that's uh,
that's right up there with like
hair plugs that just says, you know,
I don't know what that is.
That does it. I don't know.
I'm starting to change my fucking
attitudes. I guess. You want bigger tits.
You think that's bad. And if you go out
and get big fake tits, those are fake,
right? Look at those.
Those are fake probably,
you know. Well when, when they were
round all the way up to the top,
they look fake in that picture.
They don't in the training video,
you're not near the microphone.
Okay.
You just sound like some crazy person
in a closet. You look adorable.
What are you getting all dolled
up for? Fuck you. I don't buy it.
What do you even meet? Some
hipster. Is that what happened?
These vans skateboarding
shoes and is ironic.
ACDC tee shirt or Hardcastle
Hardcastle and McCormick backpack.
Fucking assholes. A mock. Everything
I loved when I was a kid. Remember?
Hardcastle and McCormick.
You always had a cool car.
Some chick he wanted to fucking bang.
And then the old guy who was too old
for this shit, it's all you needed.
BOMP bomp it up. All right. So
anyways, this guy had a Prius,
he couldn't stop the car,
so he had to call the cops.
I can't believe I fell for that one.
And people go and he was
doing like 90 miles, you know,
or really in the middle of the day. And
he had time to call the fucking police.
They caught up with them
and he didn't hit anybody.
Is anybody out there driven 90 miles
an hour in the middle of the afternoon?
I don't give a fuck.
Even if you're in Kansas,
there's going to be some asshole
drive and fucking 50 in the left lane.
So evidently that guy has a history of
a reporting back injuries and that type
of stuff. So, uh, I actually,
the more I'm thinking about this,
I'm really thinking that this is,
this is what a Chrysler did to this as
Zukie Sam arrive when it was outselling
the jeep. They just started a rumor that
a tipped over going two miles an hour.
And which wasn't true, but everybody heard
it and everybody stopped buying them.
And that was it. Like they fucked me
on the resale resale value on my car.
Who the fuck's gonna buy my Prius than
not? Even if I have all the documentation,
I swear to God they fixed
it. Um, I think the, the,
the fucking Prius is becoming, not today's
a pinto. What do you think about that?
I think I just wanted to that point where
this podcast should have fucking ended
and I'm still talking,
or if you want to see more videos
of this fucking smoking hot chick,
maybe she just got fake tits.
It's body rock. Dot. COBB.
Did I just get a look from
Unia? She is. She's smoking hot.
Exactly. Thank you. All right,
let's wrap this shit up here. Um,
I dunno if I have time to read this.
These,
these things are getting too fucking long.
Let's end with this reality TV.
Uh, Bill, I'm originally
from Boston. I heard you.
I was listening to Greg Fitzsimmons
podcasts or as he refers to it fits dog
radio and this guy writes
beyond the outer limits of gay,
uh,
the guys on the wrong side of 40.
And he's still referring to himself with
the sub ebonic hip name with some sub
robotic hip name. You know
what it really is? It's Chris.
Most people are too fucking
stupid to Fitz Simmons. I know.
Fits dog. Yeah, that's from back
in the day. I'm so, um, yeah, fit.
Say Well, you know what? He's
up. It's a great fucking show.
And now I'm going to plug
it fits dog radio and uh,
the fact that you trashed it. I didn't
even notice that. I guess it's gay.
I'm Doug. Just, I'm on the
wrong side of 42. I'm 40 also,
I should say a. Anyways,
just wanted to say,
I listen to your most recent
podcasts and I loved it.
You sound exactly like my
old friend, uh, Kevin Burke.
Uh, but blah, blah, blah. Thank
you. All this shit. Anyways, um,
your virtual reality TV and your podcast
and I couldn't agree with you more.
Nobody will remember these assholes. As
soon as this, as season two comes around,
bring back scripted TV.
I don't care if I lose my job,
at least I'll have my integrity back.
Um,
I unfortunately work in reality TV
and can tell you from my experience,
every cast member I've ever
had the unpleasant chance
to chat with thinks he or
she was meant to be on television.
None of these fucking pathetic shitheads
ever put in any hard work into it.
Making a career out of being
on TV and a over never made,
never put any hard work into
making a career out of being on TV.
They make me sick and I have
to work with them a lot. Uh,
well that's a tough fucking
situation. Um, well, you know what,
as much as I made fun of that,
that cast from the Jersey shore actually
came back for 10 grand an episode and
a,
I want to make a prediction.
I think that that that next season is
going to fail miserably because they're
taking them out of the Jersey shore and
now that they're going to take them down
to a,
I believe Miami Beach,
which I might be a mistake.
That's like when it's Sitcom has kind
of jumped the shark and they don't know
what else to do.
So they do the trapped in a cabin episode
or Greg's trapped in a fucking meat
locker with Bobby and Bobby doesn't
like being small and now he likes being
small because he can crawl through that
little fucking window. That's, that's,
that's when the show is fucking over.
When Fonzie he has to put up fucking
jumped the shark with his leather jacket
still on. What are some
other ones are, oh,
you gotta fucking introduce a cute little
kid or your dog pukes on the floor.
Cleo. Fucking love this dog. Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Hopefully it's up on iTunes. If it
isn't. Yeah, we're working on it.
I don't know what to tell.
You were fucking working on it.
And I appreciate that
people are getting meat,
getting so mad at me that I haven't been
able to figure it out or hire somebody
at this point,
because that means you give a shit,
you know? All right.
That's it for the podcast.
I'll have video next week up on bill
[inaudible] dot com of my wonderful trip
to, uh, London, Dublin and, uh,
in Glasgow, Scotland. And I'm coming
off the wagon and a hard fucking way.
All right, so I'm going to be back
next week. A little more bloated,
a little dumber, add a little something
else. So it's the magic number of three.
All right.
You guys have a great [inaudible].
Wow.
Okay.